-Performing "Motherless,"
from his album "Michael,"
please welcome Killer Mike,
featuring Robert Glasper
and Eryn Allen Kane.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Hmm, mmm ♪
-♪ My mama dead,
my grandmama dead ♪
♪ To keep it honest ♪
♪ I get depressed
and be feeling scared ♪
♪ See, I wasn't prepared
and never will be ♪
♪ To think about your destiny,
sometimes it kill me ♪
♪ You won't believe it, Mama ♪
♪ I achieved it, Mama ♪
♪ I turned these hatin' ass
people to believers, Mama ♪
♪ A Black boy
born to a teen mama, Mama ♪
♪ Gets regarded as a leader
by his people, Mama ♪
♪ If God sent me back to normal
to be next to you ♪
♪ I would gladly trade it all
'cause I be missing you ♪
♪ I be missing hugging you ♪
♪ I miss kissing you ♪
♪ I miss all the jewels,
and I miss all your wisdom too ♪
♪ Some days, I be mean as hell
and I be meaner, too ♪
♪ Fussin', fightin' over lil'
stuff that be minuscule ♪
♪ Shay and Taj tell me that's
just the Denice in you ♪
♪ And then send
both my daughters ♪
♪ Michael and Anniah, too ♪
-♪ Sometimes, I feel ♪
♪ Like I'm motherless ♪
-♪ Mama ♪
-♪ Like I'm motherless ♪
♪ My mama dead ♪
♪ Her mama dead ♪
♪ Her mama died in my arms,
mama said it wasn't fair ♪
♪ Her mama raised me ♪
♪ I told her she crazy ♪
♪ She told me,
"One day, I'm gon' be gone ♪
♪ Michael, you gon' see" ♪
♪ "That my mama wanted you,
but you belong to me" ♪
♪ And you don't understand ♪
♪ The sacrifice
that took from me ♪
-♪ Sometimes, I feel ♪
♪ Like, pullin' up
on Sunday nights ♪
♪ Just to tell you I apologize,
and, mama, you was right ♪
♪ Like a hole in my heart ♪
♪ And I wanna call the Lord ♪
♪ But I don't know
where to start ♪
-♪ Oh oh, ooh,
oh, oh ♪
♪ Some, sometimes,
I need you, Mother ♪
♪ My mama dead,
my grandmama dead ♪
♪ I miss 'em so much, sometimes,
I just cry and hold my head ♪
♪ They left the world of man ♪
♪ Like me and make sure
I'm prepared ♪
♪ To live a life ♪
♪ To make sure my wife
ain't gon' beg for bread ♪
♪ I got an altar in my home
to honor both of 'em ♪
♪ Just this mornin',
I was smokin' ♪
♪ Smoked to both of 'em ♪
♪ I asked Betty for her prayers
over my generation ♪
♪ I asked Niecy,
"Keep me through my ♪
♪ Trials and tribulations" ♪
♪ Death'll come like thief in
night and steal your joy away ♪
♪ Have you askin', "God, why You
forsake your boy today?" ♪
♪ Is this a blessing or a lesson
or some other... ♪
♪ No matter what, I'm numb as...
'cause I'm still motherless ♪
♪ My mama dead,
my grandmama dead ♪
-♪ My mother ♪
-♪ My mama dead,
my grandmama dead ♪
-♪ I'm still motherless ♪
-♪ You know, I ♪
♪ I saw my grandmother
lose her mother ♪
♪ And she just told me
"Read the 23rd Psalm" ♪
♪ God promised to lay you down ♪
♪ In green pastures
beside still waters ♪
-♪ Still motherless ♪
♪ I'm still ♪
-♪ I just hope that my ancestors
hear me when I say ♪
♪ I am truly grateful ♪
♪♪
Amen.
-♪ Sometimes ♪
-Thank you, Eryn Allen Kane.
Thank you, Robert Glasper.
[ Cheers and applause ]